so you gotta have a business mindset and
if you are in a desperate season like i
was if you're in this needs to work
season if you're in i'm serious about
this season and i'm shooting for being a
youtube entrepreneur and i'm not gonna
be a dabbler anymore you can't be
lollygagging with a bunch of lesser
things when it comes to your business
you got to get some stuff moving you got
to pick up the phone get some clients
really make a good video that's going to
lead to growing your channel you got to
identify the things that really matter
those are your income producing
activities
here's a question do you see your
youtube channel as a business or just a
place that you post videos do you see
the big picture and the path of how to
actually make your youtube channel a
full-time career
we are in the middle of a series called
taking the leap to full time and class
is in session today and we're talking
all about youtube business 101 i'm
heather torres the host of the think
media podcast the number one podcast to
help you grow your influence on youtube
and then turn that influence into a high
profit and a high impact online business
and we're going all in on youtube
business today but before we get there i
want to let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by
thinkmediasale.com
we are doing our holiday sale and i am
so excited and honored to tell you about
a brand new course called youtube made
simple course that we have available for
you in a bundle with over 80 percent off
we're teaching you how to get to your
first 1 000 subscribers and earn your
first 1 000 on youtube without a fancy
camera editing experience or 50 hours a
week to spend on your youtube channel
we're teaching you about the mindsets
that might be holding you back of being
confident on camera and our action steps
to get you to your first 1000
subscribers and beyond all of that is
available for you over at
thinkmediasale.com
so make sure to go over and claim that
brand new course at thinkmediasale.com
now we are in the middle of a five part
series over the last few weeks we've
been walking you through different
pieces of taking the leap to full time
on youtube this is the mission of our
company we want to help 10 000
purpose-driven entrepreneurs create a
full-time living doing what they love
and making an impact in the world
through the power of youtube and it all
comes down to making sure that your
youtube channel is set up to actually
profit you can't actually run a business
and actually succeed if you're not
seeing the profit on the other side so
today we're jumping into your youtube
business plan we've walked through the
law of preparation the law of momentum
the law of sacrifice and today is all
about the business side so if you miss
those other episodes you can go back and
watch them but if you're just starting
here listen to this one first and then
go back to the other pieces of the
series
in this actual episode we've broken it
up into two different parts the first
part is actually from a talk that sean
gave at grow with video live which is
our annual conference and if you want
information on that go to
growthvideolive.com
but the first part is him talking
through a piece of that talk at gross
video live and then the second part sean
and i come back on and we talk about
your youtube business plan how do you
actually make that happen and how do you
actually start to make money on youtube
all of that is in this episode so i'll
meet you on the other side of that
conversation
[Music]
number four
is a business mindset is a business
mindset
a huge essential
to those two months being the gap that
closed going to full time was having a
business mindset which means
it wasn't going into
these couple months just thinking
okay so it's youtube time let me just
make some random videos and let me just
make some random things it was literally
me asking okay what is the shortest path
to revenue what's the shortest path to
the revenue if you talk to any of the
team members
and you ask what's it like on your
weekly meetings on zoom like what what
are some of the things that come up
repeatedly on your guys's weekly
meetings on zoom one of the things we
ask every
single
day
is what are your ipas in fact it's not
even just
we have meetings on monday morning
wednesday morning and friday morning
but every single work day in slack
heather is like rise and grind what are
your ipas and the entire team responds
every single day
with the thing they're going to do that
moves the needle but specifically sean
what does ipa stand for they're like
wait you guys you drink ipa beers every
day at think media like i want to work
there no no it's not ipa the beer ipa
stands for income producing activities
so you gotta have a business mindset and
if you are in a desperate season like i
was if you're in this needs to work
season if you're in i'm serious about
this season and i'm shooting for being a
youtube entrepreneur and i'm not going
to be a dabbler anymore you can't be
lollygagging with a bunch of lesser
things when it comes to your business
well let me get some better business
cards oh let me get the colors right on
my website dude who cares about your
website right now you got to get some
stuff moving you got to pick up the
phone get some clients really make a
good video that's going to lead to
growing your channel you got to identify
the things that really
matter
those are your income producing
activities
and you'd be surprised you know you get
really focused for a couple couple
months you might be spending fifty
percent of your side hustle time seventy
percent of your side hustle time eighty
percent of your side hustle time on the
wrong things
if you're making the wrong topics you're
making the wrong videos during that time
and my friends i'm guilty of that
like so during that time i wasn't even
hitting those 52 videos super perfect a
lot of these videos you'll see up here i
had some random vlogs down at the bottom
on the page there you can see the la
tour that stuff was kind of more for
myself but that wasn't there weren't
really income producing activities these
top two videos
was us working with mix book
mix book i emailed them and they gave us
just free christmas cards no money
and i but i made two videos linked to
affiliate accounts for christmas photos
like they'll print christmas photos for
you and i knew how to see i was like
cold emailing brands and stuff and i was
like listen i'm really good
at this seminar ranking videos thing
here's what i could do for your company
would you want to maybe work together
and they're like yeah we'll give you
some free christmas cards and a free
canvas and if you review it and that's
what we did if you look at these four
videos
cool christmas gifts christmas ideas
amazon black friday deals and is amazon
prime worth it those are ipa videos
every other video on that page really
isn't an income producing video a few
bucks from adsense but what i'm saying
is through affiliate marketing those
videos are directly connected to
actually generating income if the videos
get views they're directly connected to
the intent of the viewer is hmm i'm
thinking about getting christmas cards
oh these do look nice and i'm like yeah
these are nice and just reviewing
they're like oh order christmas cards
they click the link and so i'm
generating money that's how i got to
full time during those two months look
at this page
so on this channel which i do not
recommend spreading yourself across
three channels
i
on the video influencers channel there's
really only two videos now again you
could go into brand or influence or
interviews or collaboration or
connection but again for my business
model this doesn't have to be your
business model but for my strategy of
making videos ranking them in affiliate
marketing the video lighting tutorial
the dslr video the tech under fifty
dollars
those were ipa's income producing
activities what that shows you is that i
even still i was not necessarily being
super intentional or i wasn't being even
as hyper focused as i could be it worked
out
and it was still good to take action and
sometimes mia massive imperfect action
but here's where it gets really
interesting like i was sitting on the
smartest thing the entire time and even
me if you feel like i kind of feel
confused i'm on the journey to clarity
you and me both friend like there's
there's stages this is 2015. i'm just
fighting for survival think media was no
question my greatest strength the best
brand the best everything but it was
also the shortest path to revenue
because every single one of these videos
was about gear or wide-angle lens or a
bluetooth speaker or about a luggage
scale that i i did all that because i
was going to south africa so i tested
out that how to overcome jet lag thing
and i did famebit.com brand deals that's
not even around anymore at the time and
so i these were income producing
activities
and
for those months on youtube adsense
remember i lost five thousand dollars
from my
clients
it took over three months time during
that season i earned 716 dollars in
youtube adsense
okay
um but in december of 2015
i earned 4 704
from the amazon excuse me
affiliate program
you could see on the screen you get paid
uh a couple months delayed so in
february of 2016 at the bottom of the
page at the bottom of the circle it says
4 700. so you look back to december on
the other side of the work that i was
putting in and then you see the
following months
you look on the other side of that and
you could see
that
i had crossed that five thousand dollar
mark on the other side of those two
months on the other side of the law
preparation is on the other side of the
law of momentum
it was with the business mindset what
was the what were my income producing
activities and i there was a car that
was moving that i began to steer and i
went all in with a season of sacrifice
to get to that january of now we had
replaced that lost income
so here's a question for you
is what is the shortest path to revenue
for your channel what's the shortest
path to revenue for your channel again
i do think proving picking a proven and
profitable niche and doing youtube and
affiliate marketing as so many in the
vra fam understand but the key is to
reverse engineer
for your industry and your niche you
might cover let's say you cover news we
have a lot of people in our community i
think about like bobby eberly got a
silver play button like he doesn't do
affiliate marketing he covers news from
a conservative perspective and so it's
like working with donors it's youtube
adsense because he's scaling up his
views it's it's it's all kinds like so
there's different business models i'm
not suggesting this is the only one i'm
just telling you my story and saying
that once i knew what it was the key is
to define it get momentum with it and
then you work it
what is your business plan another way
to put it would be like what is your
youtube business
plan it's kind of a weird question
because i know that when i first started
making videos it was for my church in
2007 and i started to have like little
sparks of like could i be a youtuber one
day what even is a youtuber it wasn't
even a term youtuber there was a guy
named julian smith and he had a one of
his famous videos was on malk not milk
but mulk and like you're kind of just
trying to figure out what's this going
to look like but but you think isn't
this just like the the magical slot
machine that i just i put videos in pull
the lever and money comes out like what
do you mean business plan but one of the
things we've discovered as
the journey to becoming a youtube
entrepreneur
is you gotta have a business plan and
there's no doubt about it that on that
journey to full-time it wasn't just two
months of me hustling and doing random
activities
it was going into two months of having
like knowing exactly what i was doing
because i had been through the season of
the law of preparation and i was going
in with an actual plan and executing
with focus by that time but that came
after a lot of years of wandering in
random directions and spending a ton of
time on activities that just would
didn't really move the needle what have
you noticed maybe in your personal life
or from people that we've even coached
where sometimes they lack the business
practicality of building their youtube
channel their personal brand their
business yeah and this is really good to
even discuss as so like why people quit
youtube is because there's no plan
wrapped around it they're literally just
making videos and if making videos is a
fun hobby then keep it as a hobby but we
see youtube as a vehicle for getting
your message out there as a vehicle for
creating an online business and so when
i when we're coaching people we're
seeing people who are just making random
videos this actually happens a lot in
the quote-unquote vlogging niche right
where people just want to like make
videos about themselves make videos
about the things they're interested in
but they haven't actually thought
through how am i going to monetize this
how am i going to make this actually
become a business and not that vlogging
can't be a business but it is one of the
harder ways to go about it when i think
about someone like
matthew stratton who's a part of our
community he just quit his job went full
time
last year and when i think about his way
to get to full time it wasn't actually
through massive views matthew was
diligent in making niche style content
for his exact audience he then because
he saw a trend in his space made a very
specific course for a very specific
thing and was able to then go full time
on having multiple streams of income set
up i see this with leonardo torres who's
in our community video ranking academy
he's in the entertainment niche but he
was smart and he went into youtube
thinking how am i going to monetize this
so he set up a patreon right away he set
up um he set up donations right away
people can literally just send him money
and they do every single month for his
content he's now created a full-time
living full-time on youtube because he
figured out the business around his
youtube you shared one way affiliate
marketing and you're right it's not
necessarily the thing for everyone it
makes me think of jen divorce she's in
our community she's 500 subscribers
shawn but because she has a business
model wrapped around her youtube channel
where she's coaching people on how to do
something right she's in attraction
marketing she's making 10
000
a month 500 subscribers most people
would see her channel and be like nah
she's just getting started
yeah i mean some of her videos have
literally a hundred and twelve views on
them she's making ten thousand dollars
because she understands the business
model around youtube man that's the
power of a business plan that reminds me
of carrie he does print on demand shirts
and all that he posts in our video
ranking academy he has less than 5 000
subscribers right around there and he's
doing 10k 15k 20k a month because of
multiple income streams because it's not
just about having a random audience or
just random views it's about having the
right views and so think media podcast
community should be asking like okay
what is my what's a business plan say
what's your sales plan well i don't know
i don't i'm not going to sell anything
well that's a good question to ask maybe
you should sell something or what will
you sell someday how will you sell it
what's your fulfillment of that product
again could it be a digital course or
merch or is it affiliate marketing or is
it brand deals and even if it's brand
deals how are you going to have deal
flow are you when are you going to reach
out to these brands how are you
marketing your channel of course we
would teach you use search you suggested
youtube in and of itself could be
distribution for your content but there
might be other ways are you going to
events are you collaborating so what's
your sales what's your marketing what's
your customer service what's your
fulfillment what are the elements of
your business now i totally understand
that sometimes when this is a new
concept that's overwhelming because your
answer is like
i don't know
but but shifting your thinking to this
mindset is huge in the past couple
episodes we talked about the law of
preparation during that entire season i
was studying business
you shouldn't just be studying youtube
you should be studying business yeah so
i was studying business i was studying
online business i was studying online
marketing you shouldn't just be studying
youtube
you should be studying online marketing
i was thinking about okay what are all
the different moving pieces that i need
to learn master wrap my head around that
determined what books am i reading and
then i think where this one really
becomes interesting is that question
that we ask the think media team every
single day in slack what are your ipas
what i learned is that over the years
and even call it 2010
even through 2000 even 15 16 and 17 that
i would still spend time not necessarily
on my
income producing activities another way
to put it is your highest value
activities heather have you ever noticed
that some of the people that we coach
they're like so it's like what is on
your to-do list well i still need to get
business cards i'm trying to set up my
llc i'm waiting until the web designer
comes through i'm trying to get some
brand photography photos
i'm thinking about you know i'm going to
write a blog post or two or whatever and
it's like okay maybe
all of that doesn't necessarily go and
produce income
and if you start looking at the limited
hours you have in the side hustle season
and the solopreneur season you want to
be focusing just on producing income
because cash flow is oxygen for a
business and so you want to get cash
flowing and and therefore there might be
25 video ideas you you have you should
ask
which ones would actually produce income
would it just be and i was doing some
random vlogs by the way they were a part
of self-expression hey more power to you
yeah if you want to be creative and
self-expression but like
that is not going to move the needle you
can't cash self-expression at the bank
to pay your mortgage so when you're in
this season this is the full-time series
how do you go from quitting your
nine-to-five going to full-time
you got to be hyper intentional
on what are your ipas what are your
income producing activities what are the
top 20 of the things that really matter
in building your youtube business your
youtube career your online business
focus just on those and almost ignore
everything else yeah you said it in one
of the earlier episodes and so make sure
you go back and listen to those because
we really are building these in order
you said how much is it going to take
for you to go full time right we talked
about the 25 rule of taking that leap
and going full time but here's the funny
thing we ask this a lot in our
high-level masterminds we ask this when
we're doing our online coaching we say
what is that number someone gives us
that number let's say it's five thousand
and we say okay well what are you
selling and and most of the time if you
have some momentum you already know that
you need an income right whether it is
through youtube ads or through coaching
or through selling something of course
or whatever that is and we'll say okay
how many of those do you have to get to
because for some reason when you're
unfocused on even the number of how many
you need to get to maybe you have a uh
like like um uh jen
she's selling a package let's say it's
two thousand i'm not sure her actual
package but if she's like i want to get
to ten thousand she needs five clients a
month
so now you've just allowed rather than
saying i need to make ten thousand
dollars that seems huge right when you
say i need to figure out how to get five
clients you actually start to make that
goal a lot more attainable okay now how
am i going to get five clients how many
phone calls do i need to make we're
serious as a youtuber that doesn't mean
you're just making videos it means how
many brands
do you need to email because you're
going to get no's so when what is the
number how many how many actions you
need to be taking when we talk about
income producing activities that's what
we're talking about we're not talking
about like i need to clear my inbox
i need to answer the dms on my social
media maybe yeah if that's the role that
you're in or maybe not or maybe not i
mean there were seasons sean you and i
went
weeks
without checking
we ignored social ignored social why it
was it's social media for us and what
we're building and what we're teaching
people to build
the other apps are not income producing
activities they they can be later on but
build on youtube first yeah right so
when you think about what are the ipas
it's also just saying realistically what
is the end goal what am i trying to get
to and so
then
backtracking and saying okay i need to
make i need to email six brands a day
how am i gonna do that what is my
template like all of those questions
start to come into play and you can
actually start to laser focus yourself
on what is actually an ipa we get that
question so much okay i'm gonna do an
ipa what is it it could be making a
video it's making the right video you
were doing a video on there and you said
you had reviewed uh luggage scale
p.s i don't know anyone that would
review a luggage scale but you saw it
right yeah and when i was looking at it
8 000 people have watched that video yes
okay i don't think that randomly you
know uh a person is just going to
youtube and going you know what i really
want to watch today
a review on a luggage scale yep no who's
the person looking for a luggage skill
the person who wants to buy a person
about to buy one a luggage scale and so
if people can be the person before the
purchase you will start to see your
income increase yeah whatever that
purchase is it could be through
affiliate marketing it could be someone
else's course it could be your own
course it could be your own coaching it
could be
so many things uh we teach here at think
media 51 ways to make money on on
youtube
we're just shouting out what four five
here
be the person before the buy button and
you'll start to see your income increase
i'm so glad you brought that up i mean i
think that's a cool place to kind of
land the plane but really to dig deep is
is do the math
and a business plan would have would be
doing the math another way to think
about it is how would you pitch an
investor
if you were going to sit down in front
of an investor that was going to give
you money to run your youtube channel
that's even a possible scenario it is we
don't necessarily recommend it but
imagine you're sitting across you're
saying listen i want to quit my job
i want to do youtube full-time
and here's the timeline here's the math
of course there's maybe like
conservative scenario a little bit
better scenario miracle scenario this is
what a business plan would have so
you're sitting across from an investor
maybe you're asking for six figures
maybe you're saying what this this is
what it's going to pay for it's going to
pay me for 12 months so i can support my
family it's going to pay for the startup
equipment it's going to pay have you
even really done the macro math and you
said it exactly right then what are you
going to sell if you say i don't know
would that investor invest with you so
like so how exactly are you making money
and how many of x actions do you need to
take in order to produce that money i'm
not really sure i haven't i haven't got
that far i'm just hoping that that the
fame on the other side of me posting
videos is gonna be the magical slot
machine the youtube slot machine and now
it will come coins that will
well the investor's probably gonna be
like i'll pass
so not only will this you know help you
have more confidence on what it is
you're building and of course like if
you need help with that dive deep into
our program video ranking academy
because that's about getting the
mechanics and about getting those
details and those nuances that's why we
do our event grow with video live
because obviously sometimes you're like
that's kind of overwhelming i don't know
how to fill those pieces in well again
that's what we help you with here ethic
media but what is the math
what are uh what is the actual numbers
that go behind that and the powerful
thing about i remember another coaching
we did i think it was with with jake and
i don't remember the exact numbers
but sometimes this is a scenario you're
in it could be with jen as well
your youtube channel is a long play
youtube is a long game it's building
long-term brand
long-term momentum yes sometimes you can
have success in the short term but where
your youtube channel gets really
interesting is it's like dig your well
before you're thirsty you spend one two
three four five years digging and now
there's a flood of influence opportunity
sales youtube ad revenue all that
happening but that might be the long
play and i remember talking to jake and
and he was still like getting views to
the to in the tens and in the hundreds
but then i but he was doing like
architectural and he had like an agency
or marketing for art architects and
things like that right and i was like
how many clients a month
do you need to hit your financial
targets in business sustainability he's
like two
well i was like bro actually
you should go with just your personal
brand on linkedin not even like video
and just go get two clients a month like
that's that to me that's like a word of
mouth now that doesn't negate saying
well then was youtube not the best no no
you're building kind of two things at
once but they tie together you're
realizing that like where are those
types of clients going to come from
referrals your linkedin network you know
picking up the phone making a phone call
and i remember he was bold and he said
i'm actually somewhat afraid to go get
business like that yeah and i'm kind of
hiding behind my video camera and video
editing putting out
throwing out lures into the ocean
youtube wise to just hope that i catch
clients and they come in right
well that might happen eventually but
we're asking you to do both like
whatever your business mindset requires
that's why you really figure out what it
is and to your point again i'm just
lobbing out videos hoping one day
my favorite brand knocks on my door and
wants to work with me no you're lobbing
out videos and doing the other work of
cold emailing brands i mentioned that we
discovered in that uh full-time content
entrepreneur report
that those content entrepreneurs those
youtube entrepreneurs actually spent 30
percent of their week
creating content well what are they
doing during the other 70
emailing brands and like you said
they're emailing 10 brands 20 30 no
responses all right take a nap get back
up email another 30 brands sure enough
someone responds to you you start
negotiating that's how deal flow starts
happening that's how your portfolio
starts building that's how momentum
begins to grow those become income
producing activities and when you
realize just posting random reels on
instagram or just posting random here's
my cool battle station here's my setup
like that's kind of cool but sometimes
we just kind of want to flex or just
dabble or just whatever or just sort of
look at me sophie i'm in my creative
zone today i got my creative on like
okay that's cool but like did that
actually is that going to produce income
right sitting down and actually sending
out 10 targeted strategic emails where
you've researched and found the people
who are the marketing managers and brand
managers of 10 brands via linkedin
because that information is on linkedin
via who you're following on twitter
building your network sitting down and
scheduling out the event you're going to
attend grow a video live who's going to
be there who you're going to network who
you're going to collab with really
building out the mechanics
of a youtube entrepreneur career instead
of just the selfie me on my grind rise
and grind now
sean that's what you do yeah i can do
whatever i want right right okay right
because this i if you're doing what i do
you're doing the wrong thing right
because if you're listening to this you
probably don't have a multiple seven
eight figures over the last few years
company that's a we're just slightly in
a different place you should be doing
what the people are doing there you need
to do what they did to get there and
that was
let's recap the episodes law preparation
yep
law momentum
season of sacrifice and you got to have
that business mindset and it's those are
the building blocks that are going to
get you out of that nine to five into
full time yeah you just said it right
there sean it really is about making
sure you've got the plan
of doing this so question what are your
ipas what are you gonna do next man what
are your ipas yes and we're gonna jump
into the last episode next week i can't
wait to get into it because i think this
is actually the fast track for people um
and this is you know we said in the last
episode uh man we're just telling you
how easy this is right it's gonna take
five years now we've created a system
that actually we have seen multiple
people go through actually we've seen
now thousands of people go through it
we've seen hundreds of people get
success or thousands of people with
success hundreds of people that are
probably now full time
as we're pulling people and data and all
the things but man i can't wait for
people to hear the proven system yeah i
can't wait
as well and uh we'll see you in that
episode
well i hope that conversation left you
with something to think about and i have
a question for you are you actually
thinking about your youtube channel like
a business or can we be honest and it
really is just an expensive hobby have
you actually thought about your youtube
business plan what is your shortest path
to revenue have you actually written
these things down because if it's not
written it's not real so i want to
encourage you to grab a journal grab a
notebook and just digest this entire
talk so that you can start making
success and moves forward on your
youtube channel now if this is your
first time listening to the podcast i
want to say thank you so much for making
it all the way through today's episode
and i want to encourage you that if you
liked this type of content we deliver it
every single tuesday plus bonus episodes
so make sure you're subscribed wherever
you like to consume podcast on and if
you are one of our apple itunes
listeners i want to thank you for rating
and reviewing our podcast we over
right now we have over 400 reviews on
the podcast that means the world to us
because it allows more people to see
what the think media podcast is all
about and how it can help them grow
their youtube channel as well and every
week i love to shout out someone from
that rating and reviewing over on itunes
and today comes from
nexgenrn
nextgen rn says i just need to start and
press record i've been discouraged
previously because i felt like i'm never
going to be as good as mr beast jarvis
johnson drew gooden but
they have inspired me to just press
record and i can build a youtube empire
i love that they did two episodes about
that can't wait to listen to more thank
you so much nextgen rn for leaving that
comment and man i can so relate to that
to feeling like why even get started
other people are doing this i'm not
going to be good enough but i just want
you to know that we are here for you the
reason we're putting this podcast out
trying to make it the best quality we
can trying to bring you topics like how
to build a youtube empire is because
youtube has changed our lives and not
just youtube but it's the skills of
understanding business and communication
and the pieces that people don't want to
talk about like the law of preparation
and the law of sacrifice and actually
writing down a business plan
you can do this next gen rn i'm so
excited for your journey and you just
have to show up as you and if you're
just getting started and you're just
learning how to press record make sure
you get that holiday bundle that we have
for you it is all about how to get those
first 1000 subscribers we talk about how
to film edit and upload your video we go
through the steps of the mindsets that
you have to overcome to get comfortable
on camera i can tell you that i know
this is not easy it has taken years for
me to get this comfortable on camera but
i'm sharing those principles that i've
learned over the last decade to actually
become confident to share the message
that i know is right for you and i know
you have a message inside of you that's
just waiting to get out so if you know
that your next step is to get that
holiday bundle i want to encourage you
to go there now at thinkmediasale.com
thank you so much for listening to
today's episode we have one more part of
this five part series we're going to be
closing that out next week so make sure
you're subscribed locked into the
tuesday ritual of the think media
podcast and we'll catch you in the next
episode bye did you see
thinkmediasale.com
for the holidays we're giving you 80
percent off our brand new youtube made
simple course bundle get over 1
900
worth of our best courses tools
templates and more just go to
thinkmediasale.com
[Music]